first of all the name of the album is
hackny diamonds yeah I didn't know what
hacky diamonds were but it's when dudes
who are being bad break a glass window
to rob a store or something it's a smash
and grab uh Saturday night you know gone
mad uh thing it's an English thing
London and they called them Hackney
diamonds Hackney being in the East End
of London right and the next morning on
Sunday all over the road would be this
crushed glass and you know of various
colors and they call them acne Diamond I
don't know how it works in a band but
like was that your first choice of a
title it took months to come the the
title took longer than the Record
Man why is that I don't know because I
mean after all this time what you going
to call it you blah blah blah and
there's all this but somebody came out
oh there Hackney diamonds and and they
said Bo I always thought Let It Bleed
was because they said you put so much
work into that album that your fingers
were bleeding
you've said it that your fingers were
bleeding as you worked on Let It Bleed
but that wasn't why you called it that
no no I mean title sometimes you just
say B that's it you know for no reason I
Beggar's Banquet cuz when you've been
working slaving away making a record
it's said okay what you going to call
it like oh no you know you got to and
then you've got to come up and a lot of
the ideas come from people that are
working around us have seen us working
and saying you should call it this man
you you know and and so give us some
ideas so I mean it's it's open hunting
for uh for titles this is a beautiful
song off the new album acne diamonds
listen to
this ah Rolling Stone Rolling Stones
this is your this is a muddy waters tune
yeah and you wanted to honor him yeah
and it was how we got the name of the
band in the first place
right yeah on a phone call saying we
have a gig and they said what are you
called and there was M's album cover
lying on the floor and the first track
was rolling
stone the Rolling Stones because this
phone call is costing
money beautiful song and to me this is
really what the rolling stones are about
yeah you I mean this is the basics of it
and everything else is you know this is
where it come from you
know